wow did the lights go down are we going
to do a performance good morning
everybody my name is aaliyah bundles I
am journalism class of 76 and I'm a
trustee of representing the alumni and
really delighted to be here this is
where I live and I understand that this
is not just the Washington DC district
of columbia that today we are
appropriating the ronald reagan building
as the district of columbia university
we're here today to talk about columbia
the relationship with alumni all of you
who are leaders those of you who are
already leaders those of you who want to
become leaders and how we can stay
connected to you we're really looking at
what we're do what columbia is doing not
just in morningside heights but
eventually in manhattanville in new york
city in the united states and in the
world we are represented as columbia
columbia alumni from the White House to
the Supreme Court from Congress and
throughout the cabinet we will be
hearing from our President Lee Bollinger
we will be hearing from sistant Attorney
General lanny breuer and looking at all
of the areas where we as columbia alumni
are having an impact on the world we are
delighted of course that president
Bollinger who I understand from reading
a month's worth of the Columbia
spectator is prezbo
Lee I just didn't know that about you
prismo he has really i think transformed
the way that the university approaches
and deals with alumni during his tenure
there has been a renaissance of the
columbia alumni association of looking
at how we are doing as a university how
we are reaching out to people how we are
connecting people and not just taking
alumni for granted but making sure that
we're hearing from alumni that alumni
are impacting what's going on so really
hats off to president Bollinger for
seeing the importance of this and I
think we're all feeling it that's why
we're here today happy to have provost
Claude Steele who is taking us in New
Directions in science and globalization
and I want to welcome our Dean's Dean
Carlos Alonso from the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences if you're in the
room please stand up Dean Peter on from
the school of general studies I don't
think is here yet but we'll be arriving
shortly adine linda freed from the
mailman School of Public Health my ding
Dean Nicholas lemon from the school of
journalism Dean Michelle moody Adams
from Columbia College
ding ding Modi Adams that I see you I
know she's here I saw her backstage and
also welcome to Fred Van Sickle
executive vice president for university
development and alumni relations Fred
may still be in the green room as well
and thank you too Ken tamashiro who's
the leader of the Washington DC alumni
club and who is our host so just so you
know while we're here today back on
campus students and alumni are
volunteering for Columbia community
outreach which is a student organized
service day collecting Columbia to the
community and this is something that was
started a few years ago and now there
are 10 different venues in the city
where students are being involved and
it's now in 20 different cities around
the world including beijing and london
and in the spirit of Columbia community
outreach for eight years Ted Clarkson
whose class of 73 of the business school
has coordinated volunteers from the
columbia alumni community to help food
and friends in Washington DC a nonprofit
that I'm sure many of you are familiar
with its dedicated to preparing and
delivering food to people who are too
ill to shop for themselves and their you
can all sign up for that and we welcome
you as many of you errs in there in the
room we would love for you to be a part
of it there are sign-up sheets at the
registration desk and this event will be
on April sixteenth so even though you
have two extra days to do your taxes get
your taxes done early so you can go
volunteer on April sixteenth now before
we get really started I just want to
remind you to turn off your cell phones
and I think mine is down there and my
person not turned off but i'll come get
it shortly i'd like to welcome our butts
to the stage and where are you down
there they're your come on up alice
college class of nineteen sixty-four and
law business a class of 68 that's
probably one of the first law business
degree joint was unofficial it was at a
fit well then you paved the way because
that's a big
thing right now he's co-founder and
co-ceo of her go but sand company and
gary graham collections in new york and
very active in the charter school
movement especially supporting school
for children with special needs albums